il était environ 250 à se rendre à la
salle des fêtes des essarts le roi dans
le sud des yvelines pour poser leurs
questions au ministre de la justice j'ai
beaucoup d'attentes puisque ben moi je
suis beaucoup dans l'humanitaire dans
l'associatif et je suis formateur et il
ya des questions que je me pose et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui je peux avoir des
réponses qui vont orienter on a pas mal
de sujets sur la justice en ce moment
donc j'aimerais bien savoir ce qu'ils
comptent faire sur un deuxième mandat de
l'information voir un peu ce que propose
notre mise à justice déjà et par rapport
éventuellement à ce qu'il était en train
d'être 16 qui propose éventuellement
dans les prochaines années s'il est au
gouvernement entend inviter par la
députée aurore bergé l'heure était donc
au bilan pour eric dupond moretti
écoutez si c'est pas moi qui viens
défendre mon bilan l'expliqué dire ce
que nous avons fait ce qu'ont fait les
autres ce qui reste à faire je vois pas
qui va le faire à ma place
donc c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles je suis ici bien sûr et puis
on va échanger sur des sujets qui sont
des sujets majeurs et la justice est un
sujet majeur parce que c'est le pacte
social la justice parce qu'on est dans
la dernière ligne droite de l'élection
présidentielle et que plus que jamais on
a un message de mobilisation des
français élection présidentielle est
décisive pour leur avenir pour leur
santé pour l'éducation de leurs enfants
pour l'environnement pour tout
simplement quel pays on veut pour les
cinq années qui viennent mais surtout
pour toutes celles qui arrivent derrière
parce qu'on dessine vraiment la vie de
notre pays et donc il faut faire vivre
le débat et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai invité le garde des sceaux
à dix jours du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle les enjeux
sont forts selon les dernières
estimations l'écart entre emmanuel
macron et marine le pen n'a jamais été
aussi serré